hey guys I'm Michael thank you so much
for checking out our first virtual
spectrum I am so excited about this
episode let us know what you think in
the comments below
also don't forget Mother's Day is coming
up in a few weeks so make sure you tell
your mother happy Mother's Day and
enjoyed the video see ya my preference
is for you to marry a black man who is
smart who's kind boy I love you you
still don't come to my house and we
still gonna make fun of him cuz he got
enough seasoned chicken and we gonna do
that
[Music]
my name is Felicia I am a black mother
of two little girls and I live in Miami
Florida my name is Janelle I live in
Wake Forest North Carolina and I am the
black mom to one amazing little six
month old boy
my name is Andrea I live in Humble Texas
I am a black mom to four black boys my
name is Arthur Rene I am a black mother
of a five year old little girl and I am
from the Hampton Roads area in Virginia
my name is Donna and I'm a black long to
a three year old and a one year old I
live in Louisiana right now I am Latrice
I live in Tampa Florida black mom to
three beautiful girls hip-hop is a bad
influence on children three two one go
and the songs that we grew up on like
Missy Elliott and Ciara they were
popping the beats are you get us moving
that's what makes us us but the lyrics
you guys all the times always about sex
and drugs here and there and it's
something that can be changed I know a
good amount of the R&B songs that we
have are very soulful gearing towards
black beauty nowadays but a good
majority is very inappropriate and I
think it's the wording of the question
hip hop everything is bad for our kids
it's not just hip hop and when you say
R&B 95% of R&B songs talk about sex
let's romance Sheila's when we continue
to perpetuate like it's hip-hop
no ma'am country's talking about
drinking rock and roll's talking about
killing themselves
everything is impacting our kids and so
what we have to get back to doing is
talking to our kids you cannot let music
be the sole influence for our children
right but that makes a very broad the
question
for hip-hop in particular and like you
said that's what our role is for as
mothers to teach them right from wrong
cuz I mean we were raised in that
environment but you guys are amazing
women y'all have a good head on your
shoulders and sorta why so we have to
continue that and teach our children the
same wage I feel like there's a
difference between hip-hop and rap so me
hip-hop it is biggie Tupac even Kendrick
Lamar those type of music have messages
and it gives them an open side of what
our culture is and I don't think that's
a bad thing now but we speak about rap
Megan Australian I don't want my child
listen to that or you know Nicki Minaj
I'm not really feeling that here there I
don't have a daughter to say this one
who raps I thought I can't listen today
but I do have sons who I don't like for
them to listen to and be a young boy his
lyrics like too much for them and the
things that he say from my knowledge
he's speaking truth he's speaking life
situations of his own I just don't want
that type of enthusiasm given to my kids
I know it's hard to say it's not rap
it's not hip-hop is certainly reads
because like you said we think of Megan
of style you have a lot of things that
are very empowering besides just the
things you talk about but you gotta
listen to her if that's a woman's choice
to say speak whatever she wants to speak
and us women that are attacking her for
that choice for me when I hear that
hip-hop is bad it's hip-hop as bad as it
pertains to Meg and Nicki but you're
rocking that too [ __ ] that biggie and
that jay-z
who's a whole adulterer that's okay no I
want my child to marry someone black
three two one go
I'm black and I'm proud no I'm really I
want yes I want them to be in love I
want them to be in love with a black
society we'll have us believe that there
are no good black men out there and
they're simply not sure I want my
daughter to be loved and loved will and
I don't care what the skin colour is
because then that puts her in a box to
thinking that I have to date a black man
because my mom wants me to date it
because that's what we're putting in our
children's head if you agree with the
answer that's what you're probably
telling your daughter or your son and
then that's fine and that's what you
believe in but we want to make sure that
we emphasize a lot more than just dating
a black man we want to emphasize well
how is he treating you if you're loving
you right is he leading your household
is he supporting you I guess I want to
stress that I want my daughter to be
loved because I've been hurt I don't
care it doesn't matter who I've been
hurt by I just been hurt and so at the
end of the day because I felt hurt and
she's experiencing that with the lack of
aamir not being in her life I don't care
what race II is I want her to understand
what love is
period yeah I think we have to be
careful in our conversation though in
grouping a preference with lack of
acceptance like my preference is for you
to marry a black man who is smart who's
kind who's generous and all those things
I love you still don't come to my house
and we still gonna make fun of him cuz
he got enough seasoned chicken and
preference my preference is that they
bring a nice black man home I just want
to be 95 and I have a generation of
people and then the great grand
grandkids don't look like me it's just I
mean I know it just seems like it's a
visual thing just a skin color but I
want to just have a family of just us
what we created what I mean my husband
created it's just odd to me that when it
comes to interracial relationships we
automatic assume black and white when I
think it's racial I think anyone is a
breeze so if he comes home with an Asian
with him with you know whoever I will do
my best accept her as long as
she don't try me and as long as anybody
called me it's my hair as long as you
love him for him it's not a
fetishization because he's a black man
you love him yeah monk my child's money
is my money technically speaking that
money in your piggy bank I did give it
now I'm not the mom to take it but if
I'm in dire need of it I do feel like I
had an obligation so you know not like
I'm not taking your whole piggy bank
when I was younger if you like a key you
had three dollars and your parents
ticking about pay you back a week later
can I get those three dollars back the
three dollars is in the dinner you had
last night
my daughter she had a small business and
so she made money off of her some
business and she broke a little girl's
toy one time you will go into your piggy
bank and you're going I want her to
understand and be accountable now
although I know this is your money when
something like a mirror broke on my
house because you decided to do
something you're supposed to be doing
you're gonna pay for that because out
here in the world they're not gonna cut
you no slack
I believe in whooping your child as
punishment three two one go I disagree
with it because it's not about taking
that completely away like off the table
but I try to find other methods and so I
started to take away electronics because
that's her thing I learned my child and
what she responds to I have four sons so
I don't think that that is necessary for
everything that they do especially I
have two teenagers a ten year old and a
one year old so their punishments should
all be different so my son's like to
play video games they like to sit on
their bones and those are the only
things that they really just care about
because a woman is gonna let
you know a few seconds and still get to
go back to be on their game so they are
so done with that method the hell don't
do it I feel pressure to do it now
because if I'm not doing it and my
child's not responding in a certain way
my mom is over here and my dad's like
you don't you know my own culture and
family makes us believe that we have to
use that method with my one-year-old she
doesn't he does get looked at you know
because it's more of an attention
grabber than it is I'm trying to hurt
you you know what I'm saying but the
other thing is because I'm a mother of
three girls I don't allow my husband to
do any of that okay but he's not allowed
to put his hands on me and that was
something when he talked about prior to
getting married I'm just really
cognizant of what that messaging is
right I'm allowing there a man to put
his hands on them that's not gonna work
now yeah and he doesn't have to you know
when you have a father he can just say
I'm disappointed and they melt into
tears now with me they want to try and
go back and I'm not your little friend
you know but I would support my child if
they chose to be a cop 3 2 1 go
it doesn't sit well with me I know it's
good to serve a community in the country
but as for my kids my hearts that are
walking outside day to day I just cannot
put them in harm's way it's just it
terrifies all just think about it
me personally I've never had a good
experience with cop ever the things that
we see with how cops treat us as black
people me having a black son and how I
have to raise him and educate him more
than you know the average child or
whatever is really really frustrating
but if you walked in the door as a mom I
want to go to place Academy I want to
become a cop I would have to in front of
him for it and have to all of us have
this like trepidation when it comes to
the police well the only way we can
really fix that is to have more black
and brown faces on the police first as
you know we have to start encouraging
people that are really really interested
in it I'm actually in the position now
my oldest son he's a junior in high
school and right in the midst of all of
this craziness he gets accepted into
this prestigious program that I know
nothing of because he wants to be a
detective I don't speak for everyone but
I did not have that feeling like oh
something is gonna happen to him I told
him that he can do whatever he wants to
do as long as you know he puts his best
foot forward
my child is faced racism 3 2 1 go
I said disagree because my daughter is
three and all the kids are on her age I
had a stage of just realizing what
colors are like a couple weeks ago my
daughter just told me that she was brown
Abby's always usually the only black
girl and a lot of the white kids around
her they actually want to be like her
like this wonder I was like I want a
skin like their moms dresses like it's
kind of weird but at least it's not
negative you know and I don't want to
experience that at her age it's funny
that this question came up because my
daughter just experienced a party like a
couple weeks before they canceled school
I let her wear her hair out natural for
the first time it was just like one
twist out these girl she told me that
while he was outside playing that she
couldn't play with them because she
don't have hair like Elsa and my
daughter did not understand she didn't
understand what that meant there she
came homeless like mommy can you
straighten my hair and I was like no if
so I decide to let her know like you
have hair and if they don't want to play
with you because you don't have Elsa's
hair he finds the one else but that was
the first conversation I had with her
about race because it was the first time
she ever had to deal with it so it was
kind of just like are there learning out
on their own or if that parents teaching
them that the one that stands out to me
when I have to get involved because when
I try and teach them how to defend
themselves in their culture but when
this teacher accused my daughter
stealing then that was a whole nother
conversation that I had to get into and
she had no proof I brought the principal
in she was like well she looks like she
still looks like she was still do you
have proof that she stole well she was
the only one that was standing around
the desk and so I was like mom can I say
sometimes like you sure can she was like
whoa
Melanie was saying about us too but she
didn't look like she stole anything tell
y'all what I was saying
but I said a few bangs
but my daughter she asked me is she
saying that because I'm black
I said yeah maybe he did Joe Biden is
invited 3 2 1 he's just extremely senile
because a lot of the interviews I'm
deciding it might just be time to go
golf for the rest of your life it's
enough and if you're gonna be invited to
something like the cookout which is a
black experience you gotta do better you
can't see them right over no rocking for
Joe but now I'm like I'm with you are
you see or do you just be lying no I
want to change my answer to it I don't
feel like I'm a pagoda pass to this
question because I have no idea what
she's talking about people assume that
I'm a single mother
3 2 1 go
I'm by follically personally I've felt
mentally like if I know my husband's at
home I would think that someone else is
thinking that I'm a single mom like it
just kind of stresses me out because I
know that I'm not and it's honestly not
a bad thing anyways my mom was a single
mom told my aunt they raised all of us
together so I know it can't be done I
actually had a really crazy experience
right before I gave birth to my son I
was shopping beautiful young black women
comes up to me she's like oh far along
are you and we're talking we're talking
and she starts giving me like these
resources for single pregnant women not
just like well I was like thank you so
much but I'm actually happy to be
married and you know my husband's just
he was somewhere out of town or
something like that she was like oh I'm
so sorry and I'm just like it's crazy
how just because you see a woman by
herself and she either has kids she's
pregnant I would just think oh she must
be a single mother so there's so many
biases that I had to check after I had
my daughter during my pregnancy I am a
single mom so it's so funny because I
haven't been married it's just it's
really surprising to me that married
women have just been perceived in that
light for me although it's my reality as
far as taking care of my child I try not
to think you know woe is me situation
because that's how they approach it just
because I say yes it's an immediate
assumption that I'm just a single woman
that can't take care of my child
I just find it great to know that most
of you are married as black women
because I've been around single moms and
just kind of helped me step out of my
comfort zone to know that our black
community we do have households that are
having men in them and taking care of
their kids
so it this is really it's really nice
that's a wrap thank you so much
[Music]